für den horizontalen transport auf der
erde ist der hype um eine absolut
bahnbrechende erfindung viel schneller
kommt man in der vakuumröhren von a nach
b und für deutschland gibt es bereits
erste streckenpläne aber was ist mit dem
vertikalen transport häuser werden immer
höher aber auf züge fahren immer noch
nach einem uralten prinzip bei hohen
gebäuden wenn ihre weile tonnen schwer
und drohen unter dem eigengewicht zu
reißen thyssenkrupp hat jetzt ein
revolutionäres system bundes löst alle
probleme auf einmal und ermöglichen neue
rekordhöhen von gebäuden jetzt richtig
zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
manchmal ist das leben echt verrückt in
der vorletzten nacht habe ich von einem
aufzug geträumt der komplett ungebunden
ist er kann senkrecht fahren waagerecht
er hat kein seil und weiß ich noch
geträumt habe er ist realität also ich
habe im traum geträumt dass das war ein
traum ist aber ich von etwa träume
wagnis hunter wie sondern wirklichkeit
ist und es war einer der wenigen träume
an denen ich mich nach dem aufwachen
noch erinnern konnte das allein schon
war verrückt und dann kam die meldung
und die hat sich komplett aus den
latschen kippen lassen
thyssenkrupp hat genauso ein aufzug
system gestern vorgestellt es hat genau
diese eigenschaften abseits der
öffentlichkeit wurde es entwickelt dabei
hat man sich nicht mal besonders um
geheimhaltung bemüht doch sonderlich
notiz nahm trotzdem kaum einer von dem
thema vor allem hat niemand die
dimension erkannt diese aufzug wird die
welt verändern wie der heimklub mit
dieser technologie können komplett
andere gebäude gebaut werden verfahren
die aufzüge nicht in einem vakuum wie
der hyper luft aber die werden wie der
transrapid durch magnete angetrieben das
ermöglicht ja alles die kabinen können
überall hinfahren in einem schacht
können mehrere kabine fahren und weichen
können sie quer fahren und so weiter und
so fort verfahren die aufzüge nicht mal
besonders schnell aber durch die
flexible steuerung verringern sich die
wartezeiten auf die kabinen extrem
heutzutage fallen zum teil zurück sich
prozent von hochhäusern als fläche für
aufzüge weg weil so viele schächter
eingebaut werden müssen um den
einigermaßen schnellen transport
zwischen den stockwerken zu ermöglichen
das fällt jetzt weg für die entwicklung
hat thyssenkrupp für rund 40 millionen
euro extra 1 246 meter hohen turm in
rottweil gebaut auf ihm ist auch die
höchste aussichtsplattform deutschland
höher als die auf dem berliner
fernsehturm
hier wird der multi zurzeit getestet
denn schon 2020 soll er erstmals in
berliner ist sauer eingebaut werden muss
sein wird er im rottweiler aufzug sturm
auf herz und nieren geprüft
eigens dafür wurde ein 240 tonnen beton
gewicht in der spitze platziert um den
turm in schwingungen zu versetzen und
die aufzüge unter extremen situationen
fahren zu lassen die technologie ist
dabei schon weiter
wicklung des elektromotors erprobt nur
dass sich der motor beim multi nicht
dreht sondern linear ist ein linearmotor
gerade eine schiene
wir versetzen elektromagnete keine achse
zu drehen sondern wie sitzen an der wand
und ihre magnetfelder werden nach bedarf
aktiviert so drücken wir die magnete in
einer list kabinen nach oben oder nach
unten die spacken elektromagnete haben
die kabine quasi im griff und können wir
ihn weil ich ihn fand und durch die
führung der kabine an einem
schienensystem ist es auch beim
stromausfall absolut sicher und kann
gebremst oder zum nächsten stockwerk
gefahren werden und dabei gibt es noch
einen riesigen vorteil nur bei der fahrt
nach oben wird strom verbraucht auf der
fahrt nach unten wird energie gewonnen
es wird also beim stromausfall noch
genügend energie selbst produziert um
die kabinen weiterfahren zu können das
system ist dabei so flexibel dass in
einem schacht mehrere kabinen in
verschiedene richtungen gefahren werden
können es ist die absolute zukunft und
damit fällt eine wichtige grenze weg aus
physikalischen gründen ist heutzutage
bei 600 metern schacht länge schluss
weile und kabine werden zu schwer beim
neuen world trade center in new york bis
zwölf tonnen für die seile und zehn für
die kabinen mit dem neuen system werden
im prinzip nur zwei schächte nötig in
einem wahn die kabinen nach oben und im
zeitenfahren die kabinen nach unten wie
in einem paternoster wolkenkratzer
können so quasi unendlich hoch werden
zumindest ist sie können sehr deutlich
nach oben gewachsen es ist eine absolut
neue dimension
der flug wird diese aufzug zum game
changer für den personentransport einer
der größten herausforderung heute ich
freue mich auf jeden fall schon auf 2020
werdet sicher einer der ersten sein der
mit dem multi fährt wenn er dieses und
alle anderen neuen videos nicht
verpassen wollte dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
dem video hyper luke bald auch in
deutschland
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt